If you said 1/12, nice work. This time,
I'm going to use some blocks to help me
out. This full block represents one candy
bar. I'm going to go ahead and section the
candy bar into fourths. Okay, I have 1/4,
1/4, 1/4, and 1/4, all the fourths added
together make up my whole candy bar. I
have 1/4 of my candy bar here, but now I
need 1/3 of it. I'm going to split this
1/4 into 1/3. So, this piece right here
represents 1/3 of 1/4 of my candy bar.
Let's see how it compares to the original
whole candy bar. I can see that the one
piece is one out of the 12 pieces of my
candy bar, so 1/3 of 1/4 must be 1/12. And
you probably did it really easily. You
probably just said 1/3 times 1/4.
Remember, when we multiply fractions, we
multiply the numerators straight across,
and the denominators straight across. So,
I have 1 times 1 and 3 times 4, or 1/12. This piece is
1/12 of my original candy bar.